young people are basically saying this
is where they're getting their investing
ideas from on social media
david have you seen these stats yet no
let me ask you yeah go ahead
according to a new cnbc survey okay all
right i'd like to get maybe some people
in the um in the comment section social
media right there there uh is um
is oftentimes a lot of where people get
their financial information they're
investing but is it number one is it
number one these days okay let's ask
this question so according to a cnbc
survey they asked
um
a thousand investors
age 18 to 34.
where do you get your financial advice
where do you get your investment advice
here are the options social media
investing websites
friends and family or a financial
advisor and broker let me say that again
social media
friends and family investment websites
financial advisor and broker would you
rank those one through four what do you
think i would say social media yep would
be number one number two would be
friends and family number three would be
investing websites was number what was
the other one financial advisor that one
that one's definitely last okay david
yeah you're two for two today you're
right
the actual ranking that's the ranking oh
here we go here's where people are
getting their investments so
according to cnbc this survey 18 to 34
year olds here's where they're getting
their investment advice
35 percent of their getting them from
social yeah media i've seen a thousand
tick tocks with
financial uh yeah there you go 25
percent get in from friends and family
okay so that's a quarter
another quarter 24 little bit less are
getting uh advice from investment
websites and last on the list is a
financial advisor broker seven out of a
hundred people are getting um an
investment advice from financial advisor
broker so now let's talk about the good
the bad and the ugly of getting your
investment advice from social media do
you trust social media when it comes to
investment advice dude it's i don't know
i like
when i see something i'm like okay what
do you know buddy on tick tock you know
what do you know buddy what do you know
this is just some random kid telling me
how to like save 30 on something that's
the problem and then it's like i don't
know if i trust this
bingo that's the problem thank you for a
great great uh segway into this so
here's the good the bad and the ugly of
getting your investment advice on social
media all right so what's the good
they're young they're people they're
relatable they're your age hey i know
this guy like i went to high school this
guy i know this guy he looks pretty cool
they're relatable i understand them and
most of all
it's free
that that's that's the thing it's like
why
well here's the bet people have personal
agendas like if you're a realtor if you
if you're a realtor maybe
you should buy right if you're an
investment advisor you should definitely
invest in me right were you like
sponsored by whatever thing you're
sponsored yeah what is it could be
misinformation and above all
what's the shadiest stuff out there
these days
crypto bingo yeah
yeah invest with this crypto give me
money i can get crypto the crypto the
crypto so the ugly side is that it's
risky you can definitely end up losing
money by putting your money into yeah
certain investment strategies you might
make a quick buck or you might lose it
all depending on um
where you're getting your things so
with it with with investments there's
something an investment in the
investment world called diversification
right diversification don't put all your
eggs in one basket we learned that what
the s p 500 was the other day 500 top
companies in america right spread the
risk it's not 10 companies right is that
the dow that has 30 companies 500
freaking companies some might go up some
might go down some are left some are
right but overall you're going to win
500 of them that's why people say invest
in the s p 500 yeah you learned what an
index fund was the other day you had no
clue what an index fund was no clue a
couple weeks ago
now you're one of the top index
investors in the world
i'm on forbes i have a forbes interview
next week
but when it comes to diversification you
should diversify where you're getting
your information all right so cool
you're getting it from social media but
you should also maybe get some advice
from good websites from good magazines
from good books pick up a book so
social media is i think definitely great
i mean i'm not going to hate on social
media all my stuff's on social media
pbd's on social media were out there
i think it's awesome when it comes to
general advice this is why you should
save this is how you should invest pay
off debt cool great advice but if you
want to get specific and you want to go
deep
a 30 second tick tock isn't going to
teach you all the ins and outs of
investing yeah so at that point you're
going to get a little more credible
websites business insider where we get a
lot of information forbes fortune
money magazine sauce that's uh that's
that's here usa today's got a great
personal finance section bloomberg you
ever heard of that guy pretty big barons
when it comes to investing these are
things you should do but the most
important you can do is just stay
learning right
and you should like you said question
the motivation of who's giving you
advice are they asking you for money do
they just you know they do it for the
kindness of their heart like right now
we're not asking for any money this is
we're just information for you exactly
right but people should question what
what's this guy's deal what's it oh you
know it turns out he's on valuetainment
checks out okay cool he's been in the
financial district 15 years all right
cool i get it now all right cool
or it's some guy who just did bitcoin
six months ago and he's trying to tell
you to sign up for his bitcoin investing
class yeah questionable questionable so
again diversify where you get your
information if you're getting it on
social media respect all good but also
get it from a little more credible
sources i will say that
boomers get on a lot oh okay boomer
but especially when it comes to
investing they've been investing for
30 plus years a lot of them know what
they're doing especially when it comes
to the stock market or even real estate
so i don't want to shed on that all
right so
david any final points there before we
move on no i agree i'm just looking at
the comments we have a crypto trend
saying uh social media that he gets his
information from social media youtube
discord um
got a silly white boy got it uh gets his
stuff from clubhouse is his favorite um
youtube
um a lot of people social media uh silly
white boys social media is good just
follow credible people well that goes
back to your research talk is money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauz cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken